Hey, it's me, Destin.
I'm in my secret winter wonderland spot
and I just got a boot full of ice cold water
'cos of this waterfall.
There's something interesting happening here, I don't understand it.
Umm, it looks like water droplets are standing on water droplets.
It looks like water is hydrophobic.
So, if you might have noticed why... I'd like to know. I mean I understand it probably
has something to do with the covalent
bonds and surface tension... whatever.
It's the middle of the winter here in Alabama.
It looks like when a bead of water
skates across a hot griddle it creates a
layer of water vapor underneath it.
Only that's not what it is because it's...
it's almost freezing, it's actually
a little bit warmer than freezing out here.
I don't understand it so... if you have any information,
please let me know. I'd appreciate it.